all right
it'll be a demo without slides and only
interactivity
because we can set up a laptop fine
so panda panda lang
what is this thing
it is a a programming language
and it's inspired by that i like
programming but
we've been spending a lot of time
programming
in the same way as we've done the last i
don't know
very long time and
we haven't changed a lot and that is a
little bit
concerning we haven't changed our
efficiency in programming
since maybe the beginning of time
which may be 57 we're still writing the
same amount of code
to do things which are very very simple
and actually most code
if you try to give it and explain it to
your grandmother it's going to be quite
impossible
because how you're going to explain the
curly braces the semicolons and all
these kind of things
it is quite a lot of stuff to explain
for even a small program right
so i say like this if
i talk to another programmer i can tell
you like
oh can you write a program which will
take the numbers from 1 to 10
and square this number and keep all the
squares less than 15.
this is relatively simple and is well
understood
and i met this super javascript
programmer
and he said oh be fast and he loads up
his editor he starts typing
and he found it too slow to actually
write the for loop so we just
wrote the list one comma two comma three
till ten
and it was like doing something on this
and then uh squaring them and
extracting them but it's like he had a
lot of choices to do when he was doing
this
and it took him some time it took
actually two minutes to get a program
that actually compiled
and he had to run it from node.js from a
command line and
this is the level of our art
of programming in some way right like i
tell you
can we do a program which does this you
can't just pull up your tablet
and pick away and be ready in a few
seconds
it actually takes much more and if
anyone here has ever tried a program on
a tablet okay
how did you like it everyone enjoyed it
very much
thank you so i did not
you have to get a bluetooth keyboard and
and if you don't have emacs
or vi or whatever your preference editor
is it's pretty difficult because you're
essentially
using it as a terminal in most cases and
there's a great ids which works on
your your tablet and they try to do
things but
it's toys compared to what we want to do
as programmers
these are usually not very advanced
languages and so on so
my approach is that i want to be able to
program the tablet
and how do we get there because
programming is quite complex
we have for loops we have ifs and the
syntax of this
have you ever tried to explain the
syntax of a for loop in c or
javascript for somebody this is quite a
lot of work
to understand the parts of it and it's
quite complex to actually get there
so um thinking about these things
uh if if we didn't have a for loop
if you didn't have if statement if you
didn't have any nulls
then those things might if you had an
easy way to do that then we should do
that right
furthermore uh functional programming is
great
the features of it is great because
you say what you want and it computes
this
but you look at a functional program as
a non-functional programmer
and there's map and there's reduce and
it's combinators and there's things you
cannot even pronounce
so you can't call up your friend and say
what does this
three characters mean which i can't
pronounce
and this is where the functional
programming has gone
there's still lisps which have not so
many symbols
in terms of funny characters it's more
word based
and we saw a great example of a nice
language earlier today
where tulip where it's word based it's
simple
it has processes like erlang and so on
so this is kind of
where the future goes so panda is is
again this language with a very simple
syntax
you don't need the comma because a comma
is not a has
no special meaning you could write this
but panda is actually meant to be used
more like you start with data so
similarly to tulip
you start with a value you have a value
you see the value
you can then use this value and you say
plus four
and then you just continue using these
values you can say times
2 here so we're chaining it right
this is simple object-oriented syntax
but
it's equivalent to to a function name a
parenthesis right just
we notice that in this case we don't
need to group expressions as much
it's a lucky coincidence maybe but
i like how in many languages we instead
of having parentheses and commas
we have sub-spaces but then comes the
parameter
which is a complex value and then you
need to put the parentheses around it
there
so you saved it in one place but not the
other place and it became inconsistent
why isn't why is there a parenthesis
around that expression if i put a
parenthesis run by other expression 2 it
actually looks like lisp
in haskell but that's not needed but
it's also inconsistent right
so that's that's an interesting aspect
of it so is this simple
well for math this is probably very
tedious where is the power
in in such a this language well the
power here is that
everything is a value with single values
and there's no multiple values
so can you read in the back actually
can you read the smoke okay i probably
can plus it's a little bit
all right a little bit better great so
so what does this do
can somebody pronounce it
some one to ten right
so what does it do
it gives you the value one two three
four five six seven ten
so let's see yes it did all right so it
returns an array of values
no because now you can say
plus hundred so what does this do
right so it just applies the operator
on a single value it's not
like somebody was telling me when i
showed it in in noise bridge in san
francisco saying oh that's cool but i
can do this in haskell
you cheated because you created this
plus operator
which actually includes the map and it
takes a list
and we you created all these operators
to make your examples nice i was like no
that's not how it works actually
because one to 10 is a function it
returns the value 1
and then that value is being processed
it's positive and x function
which is plus 100 and then the value 2
is generated
and it's passed to 100 so so this is a
stream of values
so every function in panda
have a possibility of returning one
value or more values
so in this case the 1.10 is actually a
function called iota
which you can recognize from other
languages which is x range in
another language so it's a generator
so generator generates zero one two or
more values
uh so how does this work we
we just eliminated the loop is it
unreadable
is it understandable it's kind of
somewhat
okay we typed very little we got very
much for it
what if we want to only get the odd
values
what should we be doing what's the best
way to get the odd values
right so we say odd
so that gives us the odd values
all right okay
that's uh fun how about
we take these values
we square them so we know that we've got
the square we then take
the values less than 15 and then we get
the values less than 15.
this is not working on a list it's
working on a
stream of data right remember this
because
even if i put a large number here
the first values comes very fast it's
continuing working in the background and
actually
this machine is so fast so you can't see
it happening but you see it blinking
green so when it's green it's working
and
when it's gray it's terminated okay
so this is a screen base it's
event-based processing right
now what
can we do with this we have something
now very simple
i would like to see if you write this in
your favorite
language how long it takes you to write
the equivalent
functionality um
some maybe some people can do it in five
seconds
one minute can everyone do it in one
minute in your favorite language
all right about 10 can do it
can the rest do it within an hour
okay great so um
what can we now do with this which makes
it more interesting because this is
this is toys right what makes it
streamed well we can do things like
you can get the time oh that's cool just
the time
from the time we can get the second
second a second we can take the time
and we can ask for the change
of a second so each second is going to
give us
a value we could also ask to get
the actual second value so we can do
that
now we can also remove it
so what can we do with this
well we
maybe can let's do that again
so we take a second extract the second
value we also change every second and we
pipe it
to s this is output of
piping it to s that goes on
we can now
read it from s and hopefully
take the odd seconds right
so each line
in panda is a process that's how cheap
they are
and you can pipe them together you can
put them together with these pipes which
wires it up
this is nothing new per se but it's a
great way to structure something
so what if we
created a
element an html called s
and we take we ask for
the dom element of s we
say that html of this should be
s what happens when
doesn't happen oh
yes sorry
to make it html
i think all right
now we're working well so there's uh
ways to connect things right so
you can actually send messages to dom
elements and and other things
the combining these things is
interesting right because
if you see everything as being a
function which returns a value
my editor is
a function and a given initial value
of the thing you're editing and each
time you save it
it emits a new value
and when you emit a new value if it
comes from a file
then you ask it to save it back to that
file
so this is a simple way of making an
editor and a file saving
independent of each other it's a stream
of edits conceptually
right
we can connect these things
in different ways for example
we can take the values 1 to 10
and we can
send them to strange loop
and if any of you there
you could actually go and
get these values from strange loop and
they will be should be updated
yes so of course this is not a
a long stream right so you have to run
it again but each time i run this the
values are sent to
the global url strangeloop.com so it's
just a url
made into a port i have a backend
service providing
communication so using this facility you
can very easily
communicate between processes between
browsers
in my case i choose to build panda
in the browser because
you don't need to install it so it's
always
available to me on my mobile phone even
it's available to people
on most devices if you have chrome by
accident somebody
tried to use it on on the
iphone some years ago and it worked
which was a surprise to me because i
never tested that
it works on firefox because it's very
compatible
and that's uh that's pretty cool
so how do you combine these things what
can you do with it
well um one example i was playing with
was
was we load a module
called cards and just defines a small
set of functions
for example a deck of cards you you have
a suite
and this have a display function which
displays
the the representation of it but it's
really just these names
and as you see this function actually
returns four values in a stream
and so you can use them we have a
function where we
can create a
cod of hearts with
just give it parts and actually this is
this is a value all right
where this value
underlying it is the actual object but
the display function chooses to display
it with right so
so you can play with this now let's say
that you actually wanted to have a
deck of cards you can then ask for
1 to 13 you get the cars
cards of that color what if you wanted
to get
all the cards well we need to combine it
with
the suit suits so we just
enumerate all the suits and then we get
all the cards of the different colors
right
of course there is a a
a way to get a whole deck
of cards each time it happens to be the
same so that's kind of boring but
let's just shuffle this this array of
elements and
each time we get get a different one
right
so um
this is a nice way to display your data
and
choose how to display it right
so going back from here
you can easily interact with other
elements so
for example my website
is yesgo.org
my language recognize that this is a ul
i don't know if there's any other
language which have ul as a data type
built in or where you can type a url and
it's recognized as a url
but actually we are in the age of urls
today right
or websites where this is a data object
and when we type it to a program it
doesn't understand what it is
maybe you need to put quotes around it
you need to import the url lib
and you need to call the new url where
you enclose it
and then you have url what can you do
then
can the computer tell you what you can
do with url
can it tell you how to load a web page
usually not you have to know which
library to use and there's a lot of
choices of libraries right
so this is where where it gets
interesting now
in panda you can ask for the html
and we can choose to put it in there
in an iframe and so it does that so it
fetches html and gives it an iframe
usually
the function names in panda are given as
to what they
return what you want to extract or what
do i want to get right
so we have this html
we can now walk into the html by
get method and we can ask to get
all the h1 tags all the
h2 tags all the
bold words things like this we can then
easily
ask to get these words in a list item
so with the shorthand syntax
where you just use a tag
as a function and it gets applied to the
element which then gets converted to
html and displayed
this all is rather rather simple
but right the sim same program this also
takes only one or two sentences to
explain
but how long it takes you to actually go
and write it oh can you go to this
webpage
this url and can you get all the bold
elements from it and
and show them that would actually take
maybe two minutes
whereas maybe the first example is a
little bit
a little bit faster so
so to describe it we can say describe
and it generates a description of of
what it does
of course this works well for for toy
examples but
maybe we have other examples which are
more complicated that may be possible
too
but this is automatically generated from
the help system
and the help system is built on
that when you define a function you also
define the documentation
for that function you also define test
cases
and so if we want to look at
a function let's say we
i'm not used to this keyboard the square
functions in the system these are the
square functions we have
let's say that we looking at the square
function
of a number now we have it here
and it knows that it's a safe function
it's a pure function
and this information we tag the
functions you implement in the
background
in the javascript or whatever
environment you have you tag them as to
what they are
and because it's a safe and a pure
function we know we can call it a
million times you also know we can cache
it
you can catch a result of it so this
gives you the ability to reason
about the functions used
in the system and
we can also just expand the
implementation
it's just a simple math square root
function right in the background
and this is possible to do for all
all the functions so let's see
here we have a function same function
more or less with different type
signature where
we have examples
these examples are actually not examples
really
they're actually test cases but the test
cases
serves as an example to how to use a
function and
and so they run it and you see it says
space div here
and it says base diff but this
you can actually run this code by just
clicking on it and you can see the
result of it and
yes it's 16 so i'm very happy right
so i like the idea of documenting things
when you go along when you add a
function you add at least a minimal
documentation to it
i noticed however the tulip we're saying
that we need to write documentation
and that is that is interesting
and it's a big job and maybe one person
sits down and writes the documentation
for whole system
but if something changes will that
documentation get updated
uh maybe maybe not right so i think it's
a great idea to
combine uh documentation and code to
keep it in one place so you update one
thing you update the other thing right
now if we look at all the functions in
the system
there's quite a lot of functions
interesting enough a lot of functions
deal with functions
so that's both good and bad but we can
for example ask which functions are pure
we can ask which functions are safe
and things like this right so it means
that
we can make a sandbox mode where a user
defines a function and we can say like
oh no this is not safe function
we won't allow you to run it because
this is a user input function so we can
actually
check the safety of something so you can
limit the amount of
data you have you're welcome to ask
questions if there's any
during the talk because the slides are
not here
that's a very interesting scenario
so feel free to ask yeah sure
yeah yes so
what it actually is is a function called
it takes a string you give it you call
the function port
creates a port and then you can send to
that port
or you can listen to the port or
you can of course
create a port from a url so those are
two distinct ports
and you can also have a port you can
create
a dom element is also considered a port
so you can send messages to
to a dom element right so
oh sorry the question was um can you
create a any port or
do you have to use the the syntax the
literal syntax right
um yes and no because i have no
variables in my language
you um so here's here's the thing
uh state i try to avoid having states
state is not necessary for processing
because processing takes data changes
and produces other changes
and these go somewhere and so
you don't always need a state
there's other ways to handle state right
like a like you could have a pipe which
aggregates things for example right so
that's a
would be a countering a counter
state but you don't have a variable
which updates
they put and get directly because this
is often not needed in interactive
interactive system
so for example to create the
i mean we can just create
that we can't do because it's not not a
actually if you say 80 port that creates
a port
in node.js which lists and which you can
listen to and actually gets web requests
so a web server is a one line in node.js
and it gets a web request from
weatherwebcast you can extract things
and then you
send data back you send html back to to
that port
but if we just create a string here
and let's say we concat foo
then we can create these ports
so you can create a port when you need
it uh usually if you want to have a like
a constant
port you use in your program which is
opposite of what you asked for
you can create a function you call on to
to generate this object each time and
it's a possibility from a system to
cache it because it would be a pure
function which it can derive
from all the functions involved right
it i understand your question because
you're saying like oh we
actually write big systems and we handle
connections
and we have state and we need to assign
a port to a specific
user maybe or something like this and
and
that kind of makes sense but because you
can construct these port names as a url
for example you can
you have your own namespace of how you
can actually build
build this thing so you don't need to
keep a pointer to it it just has a name
so you only have to invoke the name of
it and the name you can construct very
cheaply when you need it
so that's that's one approach okay any
more
questions on that okay
so i'm sorry about the slides issue
using old
old laptops is apparently not a good
idea in the future and we are in the
future here
so
of course you want to do different
things than the same simple things right
so we can easily create a
a aggregation by us calling sum and it
uses special syntax
and you can imagine this with curly
braces squishing the expression
in the middle sending all the data to
the sum function which returns a single
value or
maybe no value at all okay
let's see if something else works
so
there's ways to improve
interactivity and
naturally there's no reason why
we shouldn't be able to just type and
and get the output
for each keystroke so this
is this is trivial in these days in the
browser
of course now it turns out that the
programs
you need to type this way and interact
with the system don't need to be
very long so it takes essentially no
time
at all to do the analysis and
compilation by the way so
panda gets parsed
so we can look at our silly example
it gets parsed to something called i
call it
pandalog data log it's data log base so
this panda expression will generate
essentially a typed
data log and as we know data log is a
retractable
prologue which means it will terminate
it has a termination criteria because it
enumerates
existing data okay and then from this we
can very easily generate
javascript and you can create your own
functions which generates its own
javascript
that's how you can create a special
syntax of special type operators
one interesting thing with data log
which
most people may not be using is that
you can
you can introspect it and if you assign
cost functions to cost values to your
operators and fan out and selection so
for example the
the an odd function have a selection of
50 because in principle half of the
values
of integers will fulfill the predicate
and the fan art is one it only gives one
value in this case we can see that the
iota function
it will actually generate 10 values so
the cost
increases in the plan and we also see
that
the square function will generate 10
values and the less function
estimates the output to 10 in this case
it
will give giving giving uh
maybe three values right if you change
this to a hundred we see how the cost
says that there's gonna be a hundred
element in output
so this is a simple simple thing you can
do
um i was
looking at other things for example how
do you sure
okay so um for example you are getting a
web page
from a url that's a big cost
it's maybe on the dignity of a 10
thousand compared to doing a square or
something like this right
so you can estimate the time it takes to
run something to run some code and you
can use this
to decide to cache an operator or not
on a language level right and also you
can decide if it should be run
interactively or not while you're typing
because if it actually takes too long
you can estimate it from a cost you know
this
so you won't run it very often until the
user maybe presses return right
and uh so these are things you can do um
just want to show another thing like for
example
if you want to check if the number is a
prime number right
so we have p is 43 and assignment
doesn't yield the value so you have to
say p
a prime number is essentially when
the values there's two
numbers multiplied with each other which
yields a
which yields the number in question
right
so we can
let's say times so when these
values multiplied together yields
a a value p
then we know it is
a prime number so if we give it 42
we don't get an answer at all so panda
has the failed luggage right so if
there's no result there's no result
nothing just returned
okay i think we might have a one minute
for question or more i'm available
afterwards
okay so we finished i'm here please come
up and talk
thank you
you